how's it going everybody so right now we
have the Avengers for reshoots happening
some of the actors are done such as
Chris Evans but some of the actors
continue to shoot scenes simultaneously
spider-man far from home is filming
right now and they just wrapped up
shooting in Venice and although Marvel
tried to be really sneaky stating that
spider-man far from home shooting is now
moving to New York and not Tom Holland
and the rest of the cast and crew were
going there to finish shooting the movie
Tom Holland was spotted by a fan on a
plane that landed in Atlanta and what's
going on in Atlanta right now Avengers
for reshoots I do not think this is a
coincidence
I definitely think he's there to do some
reshoots and although he is technically
dead right now it doesn't so much really
matter for the reshoot and as we've seen
Zoe Saldana has been spotted on set
doing reshoots as well and she's dead
not to mention Dave Bautista in an
interview pretty much spoiled the fact
that the guardians are coming back and
they're pretty much all dead too
so I don't think it's much of a shock to
people anymore that the characters that
turn to dust and Avengers infinity war
it will be coming back in Avengers 4 but
the real questions are how will they be
coming back and what happens when they
do my giveaway still continues if you'd
like to win a copy of infinity war or
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray some
special edition posters and memorabilia
all you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so all these
characters that turn to dust and
infinity war are most likely coming back
I think it's just a matter of how they
come back and there are a few ways that
that can happen and whether or not they
come back by the Avengers getting the
gauntlet and undoing the snap time
travel or them exiting the soul world
somehow it doesn't really matter for the
theory that I want to talk about so my
theory is that spider-man far from home
and face for moving forward actually
doesn't take place in the same universe
as Avengers infinity war and Avengers 4
or anything before that for the first 10
years so I started to come up with this
theory by looking at leaked photos and
watching leaked videos of spider-man far
from home and there's a few things that
I've noticed while looking at all of
this leaked info and one major
is that the iron spider nanotech soot is
nowhere to be seen in any of these leaks
photos or videos in these leaked photos
and video Spider Man is either wearing
his original spider-man suit that Tony
Stark gave him in spider-man homecoming
or the stealth suit and the stealth suit
has shields logo on it so it's safe to
assume that they gave it to him so again
I don't think this is the same universe
that the events of infinity war and
Avengers 4 take place in I think has an
alternate universe that is created from
the events that happen in a vendor sport
and in this universe I don't actually
think he ever got the iron spider suit
the reason I think this is because I
think that however they defeat Thanos
whether it be time travel or the
Avengers get their hands on all the
Infinity stones and the Infinity
Gauntlet themselves whatever happens I
think that phase four is going to start
right before the events of infinity war
but danos will be defeated so the events
of infinity war and Avengers 4 it will
never actually happen so this will
create a different timeline and an
entirely different Marvel Cinematic
Universe so not only do I think that
phase 4 is going to start off before the
events of Infinity Ward but I also think
that at the end of Avengers 4 Captain
America and Iron Man are going to
somehow take themselves out of the
picture there's a chance that Steve
might go back in time and live with
Peggy Carter and get the life that he
always wanted and we know that Tony
Stark wants to have a family in fact
it's pretty much been all but confirmed
that him and Pepper have a child in
Avengers 4 so it would make sense that
Tony wants to hang up being Iron Man so
he can start a family I'm not really too
sure how they would do it that's not
really what my theory is about but with
time travel and the Infinity Gauntlet
really anything is possible so I think
they do that somehow and that again will
essentially create an entirely different
universe moving forward with phase 4
because where is Tony in all of these
leaked videos we see happy Hogan Maria
Hill and Nick Fury know Tony and why is
happy talking to Maria Hill and Nick
Fury is he in charge now if Tony's not
there I think happy will be in charge
and if Tony's not there happy is most
likely looking after Peter Parker as
well and that explains why Nick Fury and
Maria
are talking to happy and not Tony so
Tony's not there and Peter Parker
doesn't have the iron spider suit again
because the events of Infinity Ward
never happened so he never got the suit
and remember Avengers 4 is supposed to
wrap up the first 10 years of the MCU
all of the stories that happen within
the first 10 years are all going to be
done so how do you wrap up the first 10
years but still have some characters
that existed throughout the first 10
years moving forward
well you alter the timeline and events
that took place and you create a
different universe moving forward this
also opens up a lot of different ways
that you could introduce the Fantastic
Four and the x-men into the MCU now of
course they could always just say that
they existed the whole entire time or
you can say that somehow altering the
universe somehow had a huge impact on it
and now mutants are here I think it
opens up many possibilities and creative
ways to bring them in so this is why I
think that spider-man far from home and
face 4 will take place in a different
Marvel Cinematic Universe than the last
10 years it'll still sort of be the same
universe just altered a little bit and
this opens it up for characters that
already existed to stay but also new
characters to come in obviously this is
just my personal theory of something
that they could do to start phase 4
since they did say they were wrapping up
the stories from the first 10 years so
let me know what you think in the
comments below
and if you have any theories of your own
let me know don't forget to subscribe to
my channel like the video and comment
below so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything related to
Avengers 4 and Marvel as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]